- [Kelly] I feel like--
- Yes!
- Y'all are both in like
pinks and bright colors.
I've got some bright colors going on.
- The girls are sitting pretty.
I am giving you Real Housewife of Wakanda.
Let's go.
We look cute.
This going to be a music, y'all!
- Wakanda! Meet Emmy, have
y'all ever met before?
- [Emmy] No!
- We've never met before,
so lovely to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- I'm a fellow musical theater
nerd so we gonna get along.
- We're all musical theater nerds then.
- I mean, duh!
- Oh no, but I don't know if people know
I was into musical theater.
It's funny, I don't like doing theater,
but like musical theater,
you add music and I'm in.
- [Joyelle] Absolutely!
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- If it's just talking
I'm like meh, can't do it.
I'm nervous about that.
But you worked as a
teacher. I didn't know that.
- I did work as a teacher,
but I also worked as a server.
And let me let y'all know.
- Me too!
- Best tipper in the business.
- Wait!
- We met before at the
Cheesecake Factory in the Grove
and you tipped me 50%, oh my goodness, so.
- What? I didn't know that!
- Yes! You don't know that?
You don't remember that?
- Oh no, here's the thing.
So I was a waitress and
I always told myself,
because you work off,
you live off those tips.
- Exactly.
- And I was like, if I ever make it,
swear to God I'm gonna tip, I told God.
And I do, I try to tip
well, you're so nice!
- Oh my God, because you better tip
because the servers will drag you, okay?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They'll be like, you ever
tip Kelly Clarkson, good lord!
- No, I love that. That's so awesome.
I love that full circle.
- Yes!
- So wait, but you were a
teacher and I didn't know that.
- I was a teacher.
- You were a funny teacher.
- Oh my gosh, I was a great funny teacher.
I taught in South Central
Los Angeles in middle school.
So yeah, I'm not.
- Middle school's hard.
- I'm not on regular birth control.
So that's like theoretical
birth control. And--
- That's hormones!
- Exactly. And then I
also taught rich kids
on the Upper West Side of Manhattan.
So, juxtaposition.
- [Kelly] I'm high, low.
- They both have absentee parents, so...
That's the real tea.
- Oh my God! That's so true!
- So wait, do you think that
you could have been a teacher
ever in another life?
I couldn't have.
- I don't know what. I mean,
what do you, what does it take?
- Patience?
- Actually, like how much time do we have?
- If you're in middle school
you need to take a child
roasting your outfit.
That's what you need to take.
- They're mean.
- Yes. They'll tell me,
"Girl, that ain't it".
You know, they'll make you burn an outfit.
- No, I think it takes
patience, like so much patience.
My mom was a teacher and
I was like ha ha, nope.
- [Joyelle] Yeah, nah.
- Not for me.
- I didn't have the patience.
I got fired, so it was fine.
- I know, I was,
my question was gonna be
like from your stand up,
is that when you got fired or you quit?
- Oh, I fired.
I've got fired from South Central
and I quit Upper West Side, so.
- So wait, were there any other career...
were there any other career plans?
Like other than this one
if things didn't go how you wanted?
- I lived with a dominatrix and she, yes,
she taught me about
financial dominatrix thing.
I don't know if anybody
knows what that is.
That's basically you get a dude
who wants you to spend his money.
So I was going to look into that.
- I was going to look into that.
- I was going to look into that, you know,
send the resume out.
- Oh my God!
- I don't know how you get that.
- You are so funny.
Congratulations on your comedy special.
- Thank you!
- I can see why it's amazing.
So wait, it's called "Love Joy".
So you taped it on your
40th birthday, right?
- I taped it on my 40th birthday.
I know she cute. You didn't think.
I taped it on my 40th
birthday, yes. It was amazing.
- This is my 40th year.
- Is it your 40th year?
- [Kelly] Yeah, this is my 40th year.
- You were a 81 baby?
- 82 baby.
- Yeah, 82 baby.
- Okay.
- 86.
- 86, okay.
- Not in the club.
- You are so young.
- I know, right?
- Did you have a party?
Because you worked.
- Did I have a party? Oh
my God, that Airbnb host
will never let me host ever again.
How you going to rent out a whole house
and not expect people to
have a party? Come on.
So yeah, we had a party.
- [Kelly] I love that!
- Yes.
- Celebrating for the next 40.
So wait, have you ever had like
a memorable party like that?
Like, I don't know if
we've ever had a party
like she just gave us a vibe for, but--
- No, but I want to be invited.
- [Kelly] I want to be--
- Oh I'm a good time, if y'all can't tell.
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah. One of my friends,
she gives people advice.
She's like if Joyelle ever
invites you to a party,
go because we going to have a good time.
- [Kelly] I love that.
That's fun. You got to live life.
- Yeah.
- So wait, so before we go,
so I hear that you have
an apology to make?
- I do. Okay.
So the way I got booked on the show,
I was at the Critics' Choice Awards
and two of your producers
were at the table.
And Dave, who is an
amazing person, he was,
yes, over there in the blue, he cute.
He was booking me.
He was like, you should
be on Kelly Clarkson.
Because I told him you tip well.
And as he was booking me
my cousin was over here and she was like,
girl, Venus Williams is over
here, let's go take a picture.
I run away from him
to go take a picture with Venus Williams.
And when I came back, I was like
did y'all see me talking to Venus?
And my producer was like Joyelle,
he was trying to book you
for "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
and then you spilled red
wine all over his tux
after I ran away from the table.
So I apologize, Dave, profusely.
- Wait, but wait. How's, oh,
Dave, that's a rough one.
- Yes!
- How is your shirt and tux now? Is it?
- I mean, it was a little
messy, but the shirt survived.
We're good. We've made a work.
- I'm just going to say I love you
and I'll buy you another shirt.
I think Venus was worth it, the run.
- [Joyelle] Absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah. Worth the run. Yes.
- Absolutely she was.
Because it was a black
girl magic selfie so...
there was a lot going on in that building.
It was Halle Berry, it was
Will Smith and Jada Pinkett.
I just, I was googly, I be starstruck.
So, look at that.
Yes!
Amber Ruffin, Jodi
Turner-Smith, Venus Williams,
Danielle Brooks, and my cousin Joy,
who was the bold one that
said let's go over there
because she's an Aries from
Atlanta so she's very bold.
- [Kelly] Oh, Aries are bold.